j'ai une très mauvaise nouvelle giuly je
commence l'émission par une nouvelle je
sais pas si vous avez vu maints articles
est sorti dix ans que les boîtes de nuit
fermé les unes après les autres
et ouais en 40 ans le nombre de
discothèques a chuté de 70% en passant
de 4000 dans les années 80 à quelques
1200 aujourd'hui est-ce que vous allez
encore en boîte auto de la table non non
non isabelle en boitant qu'est ce que ça
m'emmerde on n'entend rien on regarde
avec vous n'êtes pas allé en boîte
trois ans mais aussi trois ans mais
c'est oui c'est pas longtemps vraiment
que vous avez tous aux boîtes en boîte
de nuit à annecy
non c'était cool mais aujourd'hui non le
prêt je me suis emmerdé coyne enfin de
toutes les boîtes ou fait tout
[Rires]
et est ce que moi je moi je me rappelle
moi j'allais en boîte de nuit à chaque
fois j'avais un truc qui se dérouleront
il faut pas jouer avec la nourriture en
plus c'est que j'allais j'allais ans en
boîte et jamais du saumon fumé sur moi
et maintenant la vie de ma mère acharné
du sommet j'amenais du saumon fumé sur
moi et pendant que j'avais des copains
sur la piste géant résister en béton sur
la mer que ces brides ans cellex c est
tout le monde rigolait genre le mec
croyait et au genre d'élèves venus et
c'était les stocks de bois il avait des
saumons il voyait pas il s'est battu
dans ses copains c'est tout il dans ce
set puis on la sait gré et le mec après
est bonne et qu'il avait des tranches de
saumon ici mais on faisait mais au fur
et de rires c'est là et ça pourra alors
pour après pour les meufs
je vous lis à la baisse ses marges le
dit et on approche c'est exceptionnel
oui parce que après la bulle à narnia du
saumon après je voulais déjà dit j'avais
un autre rue cambon en boîte c'est que
nous les tunisiens
quand on sort de chez nous on a des
coiffures de ouf alors des coiffures
d'où ça vient au métier je me rappelle à
l'époque le pento alors je le dis je
sortais de chez moi un mam est renvoyé
mais quel beau gosse sur ma vie je
sortais j'étais farm et une fraîcheur
mais bradley cooper mon frère et je
sortais mais le problème c'est que tu as
une durée de vie de la coiffure limité
on était déjà en voiture on se dépêcher
près on rentrait et on avait un code en
boîte parce qu'à un moment jours à moi
chaque fois donc on parlait des mof en
bois et y avait un copain à nous qui
était chargé de faire le tour des autres
potes à ce thème et ses peines
exactement c'est monsieur penneteau
kravis d'arriver comme ça et quand tu
parles avec une meuf qui voyait que tu
avais une boucle
deux pattes les tours sauf tu sors tes
bras des coûts au bout d'une heure tu es
patrick timsit joue pas donc c'est comme
ça il avait un mec qui arrivait mon
frère et qui faisait juste un truc et
les ex-aequo masse est venu dans
l'oreille il faisait frères te tais dans
l'eau mais vite aller vite que tu as une
pommette la tête sous l'eau mais ouais
il contraire tout est dans l'eau mais
vite vraiment les gens j'ai pas je
l'écouté pas genre mais revenez sans mel
tormé je t'ai dit vite jeté dans l'eau
et donc y avait un mec qui faisait le
tour comme ça on allait à ce direct aux
toilettes on salam up tant de minutes je
reviens parce que j'ai un truc à faire
la toile a souvent on revenait une
demi-heure après loana est vrai comme de
l'eau de roche
un jour on emboîte times of moi je vous
dis toutes les semaines elle est là et
j'ai tous mes copains qui se sont cassé
les dents sur elle et j'ai un copain à
moi
lui c'est attila ça veut dire si lui ne
pêche pas personne ne pêchera je vous le
dirai et donc qu'est ce qui fait un peu
tard mais il voit que je suis avec la
meuf et voit que ça passe d'être il dit
ça commence à un truc il vient dans la
boîte
bonjour c'est vrai un chèque la meuf
essai c'est chaud ça vient
il vient me voir il me fait je peux te
voir deux minutes sinon mes frères se
faire après on va faire le chemin
ensemble pour un gros cigare après bino
jeu de voir tout de suite julien on dit
il faut que je te vois il ya une
embrouille vient vittek moi il m'a mais
des coups droits bien on sort de la
boîte ils m'amènent il me fait marcher
mais bien 500 à 800 mhz et 30 mhz et non
là j'arrive
si c'est oui au moins une vidéo même je
crois ça fait trois semaines que je suis
sur la meuf qui continue à rêver du
maintien
[Applaudissements]
encore dans la boîte après la mode
l'épousa oui moi c'est pas beau ni riche
ni célèbre est-ce que vous rentriez
facilement on n'est pas chez moi
reprendre la question déjà vous plaisent
pas vrai vous avez été mannequin on
avait il vaut mieux être au top
sean est au top après deux faciles
center mais c'est vrai les chiffres et
si vous avez des trucs boîte vous vous
en arrivez eric moi je suis allé cinq
fois en tout dans des boîtes dans la vie
de teck a toujours été un gars je suis
allé cinq fois ont tout pour faire
plaisir à ma soeur à mon ex
voilà je me suis endormi deux fois alors
je me suis endormi deux fois en braille
ou en bois et une fois j'étais invité
une fois très sélect pas vous souvenez
de christian audigier bien sûr très
jeune super soirée à cannes tout se
battait pour entrer il m'avait donné un
ticket d'entrée au bout d'une heure je
m'ennuyais tellement j'en voyais un
amour pour lui demander s'il y avait pas
un coin dans la boîte on pouvait lire
non il m'a dit non mais que c'était la
première fois qu'on lui envoie dans la
boîte on pouvait chi
farida hammiche situe si on veut pas
pécho kevin un témoin mais moi je vous
dis raconté j'ai raconté aux
téléspectateurs
ouais moi un moment pour rentrer en
voiture et pour d'autres questions voilà
c'est vrai que j'avais vu je regardais
m6 et il y avait marqué sur m6 il y
avait un mec qui s'appelait thierry
bisou qui était directeur m6
et qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai appelé à
6 maintenant moi j'avais une petit frère
a rien à voir avec le directeur des
divertissements existe j'appelais la
boîte avant je disais oui bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur thierry bizot je vais
passer ce soir avec deux trois amis même
où j'allais à l'époque c'était la boîte
de jean roch c'est le passé j'arrivais
de vente et donc premier jour j'arrive à
limoux ce soir je suis tiré mise au jeu
il avait calé le fils de missiles à
avoir gonflé il ya télévision jean roch
sortie thierry bizot alors un premier
jour donc jamais de faire au début je
venais j'étais tranquille je venais avec
un mec et neuf sur tranquille on a trois
jeux lors que ces brefs semaine d'après
je râle and his encore thierry bizot
venir là frère la semaine d'après on
vient là il ya jean roch qui sommes
faits oui il a il ya plein de monde en
fait tiens j'ai laissé passer thierry si
vous voulez télévision m6 tient les
musées je rentre là voilà truc ça c'est
la deuxième semaine
troisième semaine vous jure c'est vrai
on vient jouer à 15 bien coachée il a
connu je crois qu'il a diarra koné en
plus simple ce qui a primé il a vu que
c'était une supercherie
il me fait rentrer on faire et là il
m'offre une bouteille de champagne et en
plus il met la table bouteille de
champagne que ça et moi je connaissais
des mecs dans la boîte mais qu il
m'appelait à nous et à 50 jor-el pas
céder tiens ça va durer
raconte m
[Applaudissements]
t'inquiète pas tant de temps à perdre
avec ça et un moment je l'appelle ils
sauront que boire il dit ouais
j'aimerais même proposé un projet pour
m6
quoique c'est dans la merde je sors de
la boîte et nigériens de proposer un
projet pour 1,6
je fais écoute là je pars en afrique
parce que là je vais développer tout m6
va tu vois mais à mon retour je
t'appelle donc là j'y vais plus et je
vais à saint tropez pour les vacances
et là il y avait une boîte et genre
d'appareil c'est terrible je suis sur
130 figure toi mon jour là j'arrive jean
roch pareil vient mon frérot on va voir
j'ai hélas la poche le point un peu à
côté de moi parlons un peu de tes
projets tous ept nationale c'est ce
qu'ont vu les films se produit
maintenant moi je suis pas du tout dans
la télé mais moi je vendais il me dit
mais des chemises sur le marché là c'est
vrai en plus ça je suis mathilde or
c'est sur le marché donc frères et là le
gars il me fait la finance est un beau
projet je pense qu'on va le faire ça
donc le gars est là il est persuadé que
suit thierry bizot le problème c'est que
deux semaines après le rock est à saint
tropez et là on lui dit il ya thierry
lefever sa boîte à saint tropez
je rentre il voit comme ça il fait lui
si la mise au jeu c'est à dire qu'on lui
sait
[Applaudissements]
je connais thierry bizot n'y a aucun nom
fait rêver c'est ok vous le faites une
fois vous dites ok si vous n'êtes pas
oublier que celui-ci annonce avait
poussé oui et après donc la ja ja til
the rock indie non mais je connais
thierry bizot et là il ya charlie lui
qu'avec la moitié des chalets lui et la
jeune va boire ci a dû lui fais tu as vu
il ya un mytho qui veut se faire passer
pour tous et à l'époque d'une machine et
la charlie lui font pas non mais c'est
vraiment agréable
pourquoi lui soutirer des zones mais
c'est oui mais attendez que je croyais
qu il se fait passer pour télévision
depuis des semaines et même des années
et là donc il fait rentrer thierry bizot
mais voilà et un jour il ya comédie
invités il voit un mec à poil
[Rires]
dernière godoy cern
on n'aura plus tout ça est assez grave